ragazzi non mi aspettavo minimamente
trovato un secondo impreparato benvenuti
ragazzi dopo anni di ricerca finalmente
abbiamo trovato
l'ufficio è quello che sta volgendo non
è il mio stomaco bensì il capo prima di
iniziare questo video devo fare però
minniti cappello introduttivo per
spiegare un pochino che cosa è successo
e poi e soprattutto quanto quando il più
piccolo vabbè non così tanto piccolo
sono partito la mia cameretta quelli
sottobicchieri e con i miei fratelli
giravamo come se fossimo una gang di
scappati di casa con strumenti da
pitture rupestri e una professionalità
pari a zero nel contempo iniziato a
migliorare anche gli strumenti o
personale reflex delle luci ho preso una
casa nuova
il sata mostrare mi sono appoggiato
l'agenzia per iniziare a girare i video
di cucina poi da lì è arrivata la grande
scommessa quella dei primi un'agenzia
con i miei parenti
la cucina diventata inizialmente vola di
mio cugino è poi quella nella quale in
realtà ho sempre cucinato da quando me
lo spirito nella nuova casa inefficiente
sono diventati gli studios e kasami e
ogni tanto vi abbiamo portato fuori con
noi tutto questo sempre cercando un
posto del quale poter lavorare e
trasformare quel piccolo su un iniziale
in una realtà vera e proprio nella quale
poter dare il massimo
partiamo dal posto più importante di
questo ufficio quello da qualche siamo
fuori la maggior parte delle nostre idee
seguitemi accesso avremmo potuto
scegliere un su questo è un paio
calcolate che abbiamo delle idee
particolari per questo nuovo bagno
innanzitutto capo stick e francesca
abbiamo intenzione di fare tutto quanto
di un solo colore a chi indovina di
commenti del colore volevo fanno tutto
quanto dice mille fanta soldi
probabilmente diventerà un libro
costiere quelle persone si possono fare
i santi accesso ma con stile questo cui
il bagno semplicemente già sette ore a
prevedere il bagno non riuscirò un'altra
viene di tutto quanto mi raccomando naga
se avete dei consigli scrivetemi qua
sotto perché le idee di alcune delle
stanze ancora non sono proprio
chiarissime eventi perché ero qua se
qualcuno sta già cagando là dentro c'è
un piccolo l'antibagno ebbene questo
termine al pavimento ragazzi non è così
in tutta quanto l'ufficio di base per
questo bel marmo rosso altri colori che
non riesco a vedere segue milani nella
prima cosa che vorremmo fare non appena
si entra è riempire questa camera con i
voti
questo studio saranno la linea graziana
siria per questa stanza in realtà per
richiamare un pochino anche il sotto
sara cosi nel deserto o safari
vedremo i colori sabbia e crede
il giardino verticale ed erano presenti
moltissimi ringraziata che di base sono
aride ma ogni tanto e pd erano fuori
quella per l'acqua
qui corridoio enorme qua e dove il
momento più di tutto perché non ha posti
dove sedere napoli niente con il tratto
buttano le nostre scorie sia un volume
quelle specie animali che si nutrono
delle loro stesse feci facendo questo
circo non ne continua ad alimentarsi
avevo un impatto ambientale pari a zero
no io sono d'accordo degli atti il test
dell'ingresso ma che cos'è just del
inglés sulla persona ti accoglie così
tirato dovremo fare il cazzo di caffè
che se fanno tutti quanti ogni giorno
con un enorme bidone con su scritto
buttato nella di terzino con dentro
ragazzi seguitemi
entriamo nell'altra l'ala ovest abbiamo
questa stanzetta questa che la stanzetta
dei ragazzi ho avuta quanto i nuovi
enorme ne esca con i computer per
montare le serie la postazione di unisce
visto che ho bisogno di computer forti
per trasmettere in tanto che quest altro
lato avremo tutta
una parete nera il mega logo l'azienda e
di mamone in modo che ne potremmo
sederci a piero stream e con buone e
stare insieme poi stiamo per andare in
una delle sale più buie ma allo stesso
tempo e sala del lussuoso capo non avrei
minimamente è venuto in questa stanza ma
hanno insistito tutti quanti a fini è
assolutamente è la stanza più grande
pazzesca ha una base pentagonale
la strana scrivania con l'occhio
sinistro controllo quello che fanno le
ragazze stanno alleati del futuro quello
che innesto controllo quello che fornì
ragazzi credo che mi tronchi e delle
telecamere sorveglianti mentre lavora
non puoi quale angolo lanciando un caffè
subito mi può discutere caffè è
scambiata a quel punto forte di cambiare
passiamo adesso la sala riunioni
qualcuno sta già vedendo e l'ha già
vista all'interno delle mie storie su
instagram raccomando sempre non eseguite
su instagram fatelo subito e soprattutto
questo è il vostro momento ragazze
questo è il momento di far parte del
sogno io ringrazio tutti quanti voi
perché grazie a voi che oggi noi ci
troviamo all'interno di questo posto
meraviglioso ma alcuni di voi ancora non
sono iscritti a questo canale e quindi
se in questo video deciderete di
mettersi una mano sul cuore e di
cliccare iscriviti
voglio far parte del sogno mai convinta
che ora prevede ora michelotti this
iscriviti di scrivere questa è la nostra
meravigliosa meeting room
prima c'era un parquet simile a quello
degli ufficio ma siccome la faremo tutta
quanta che sembra un disegno abbiamo
deciso di coprire tutto quanto è creare
un finto barchetti segnato quella che
questa abbastanza che prende spinaci
rinnovarsi nulla andremo si aprirà leoni
sia per le cose il caso siete ridicoli
clienti sia vera delle presentazioni ma
soprattutto la utilizzerebbe piero un
progetto super super super speciale
all'interno di questo canale su per la
riforma non posso dire altro per
prevedere perché ritorno ci facciano un
passo avanti del futuro qua
dovremo fare un lavoro totalmente di
bonifica la meraviglia di questi fiori
la cui avremo una zona di mega relazzo
avviamente manterremo le piante
mantenendo tutto quanto il dos tres di
canto il giocattolo della nostra cucina
ma no io vicino dedicata al marito
catechismo ragazzi che cosa potremmo
fare qua perché vedere chi scende
abbiamo un altro piccolo fazzoletto di
terra che io perdo non sappiamo cosa
farci di sicuro non morto mago altra
cosa stupenda di questo ufficio è il suo
secondo ingresso con tanto di scivola in
modo da eliminare qualsiasi tipo di
barriere architettoniche renderlo il più
inclusivo possibile scivola che ci
portano stati con me i miei occhi mi
raccomando sono qui son come faccio con
questo po po per questa piccola diciamo
corridoietto con
gajan piante insomma è tutto quanto
abbastanza in divenire
cioè 45 è proprio piacevole bisogna
veramente capire cosa farci pensa oppure
che ne so di metterci un amaca però
capire che sono pure in bocca alle
persone che bassano sembrerebbe finito
il giro ma c'è un altro posto che devo
per forza fate vedere perché voglio
starete chiedendo ma dov'è che mette di
setta vi faccio vedere pochissimo
allora eccoci qui questo qui del famoso
test con la persona che dovrebbe avere
veramente un colpo dinoccolato seguitemi
quello che succede è che oltre questa
roba qua che spaventa meno radicata
d'ufficio è cambiato non sa nemmeno cosa
voglia dire cablato c'è tutta una zona
sotto c'è stato il non ci posso dire
cosa un piano sotto sì c'è un piano
sotto se lo avessi fatto vedere qualche
giorno fa e anzi sì abbiamo delle
riprese vele mostro perché perché
abbiamo degli operai pazzeschi che sanno
tendenzialmente ristrutturando tutto
quanto
andiamo dove è andato io ma cos'è questo
dice timidamente riscattarsi mediana
gianmarco per fortuna questa croce
datami in dotazione col telefono
gianmarco
non so dove possa essere si sa
se tu c'è nessuno
ma
[Musica]
mettono mascherina perché così almeno vi
posso far vedere il dato che c'è gente
che sta lavorando io sono stata la prima
persona ad aver percorso queste scale
quando vidi l'ufficio la prima volta se
ti ricordi è un'altra storia qui
innanzitutto bisogna mettere
l'illuminazione quindi sempre un pochino
buio perché non c'è la luce questo
questo è l'anno i nomi a magazzino
all'interno di questa vostra mettere
così curamente macchinari tutto quello
che ci possa servire ragazzi cioè anche
perché la linea un'altra zona
questo qui come potete vedere tipo feste
balli e canti mariani ma vuoi prendere
un patto maker ma non era quindi la
prigione base uniti abbiamo tutta quanta
la zona e la quale inseriremo molto
probabilmente roba da giammarco marco
toma centro del caso la voce quello
dell'ufficio di jamar di ci troviamo
invece all'interno della prima stanza 7
tutto quanto vita buttata i nuovi format
più legati a chiacchiera esperimenti
mari differenti
può succedere abbiamo già un'idea
attivissima per questo ufficio che non
vi dico perché qui tutto quanto già
settato meraviglioso e coop ha trovato
una zona seduta e compagnia bella
mettiamoceli visto proprio un sacco di
spazio molto probabilmente metteremo
tutti quanti rifondare i neutri quindi
dalla parte per un set già fatto ed
attaccate dall'insetto un pochino più
versatile quindi per in il nero il
bianco e tutti quanti questi vari colori
che possono scendere più pero possiamo
arrivare a seconda di come gira o a
seconda del progetto particolare che
vogliamo fare uscendo da qui abbiamo
questa stanza ragazzi potrebbe diventare
in futuro una seconda cabina regia
perché l'unica che può stare ugualmente
distante dai set
al momento è utile quando un anno sul
gomito c'è la cui somma al bagno adesso
grant e quindi se uno si sta parlando
sotto ti metti la merda sulle scale
disperata oppure filippo lo vuole la
finanza compari qua pesa che sarà la
nostra stanza m ultima stanza grande e
importante
questi ragazzi è già di per sé una
cucina che noi andiamo a smantellare
completamente perché all'interno
dell'attuale metteremo enrico quanto
etica
un'idea ma soltanto rivedendo accusate
l'audio ragazzi perché è veramente vuoto
quindi il moma tatto che lo dico su da
subito è un concept epico epico assurdo
pazzesco
sicuramente c'è lo prego il bancone con
fornelli tutto quanto è fuori terremo
lavello dispense in modo poter avere una
cucina che sia fatta proprio per
intrattenere e basta se un corridoio
arrivò solo il rischio di corridoio che
porta a un'altra uscita queste due
l'uscita del papa quindi quando c'è
qualcuno che ci aggredisce un cattivone
possiamo fuggire e scappare questo è il
piano d'impresa diamo allora mi sono ri
piazzata all'interno di questa stanza
perché quella per il momento un pochino
più carina o chiudo e concludo questo
video con un enorme grazie un grazie
gigantesco fare questo tipo di lavoro
può sembrare una rubata stata sempre la
pena foto fa in video ma spesso dietro
c'è un lavoro enorme e il lavoro è
legato principalmente che funziona
solamente il momento in cui ci si
diverte nel modo in cui c'è qualcuno
disposto a divertirsi conte ha disposto
ad ascoltarti ecco perché continuo a
dire che questo qui non è un traguardo
mio o della mia famiglia mentre guardo
per me di tutti quanti noi tutte le
persone che ci sostengono che ci sono
sempre state persone che solo ritornare
anche io per esempio ho avuto due anni
nei quali mi sono allontanato dal canale
ed è stato solamente a volte il calore e
il sostegno delle persone che ne hanno
poi spinto a continuare purtroppo siamo
esseri umani e come ogni essere umano
volta hanno bisogno appena bella pacca
sulle spalle per poterci dire ce la puoi
fare continua così un benvenuto
naturalmente a tutte le persone che ci
seguono da poco che ci seguono anche
solo data adesso un benvenuto a tutte le
persone che verranno abbiamo delle idee
ragazzi sono belle belle
uno dei motori che mi spinge e cerca di
avere sempre idee più belle è quello di
divertirvi intrattenervi e soprattutto
darvi un senso di casa perché non sempre
abbiamo tutti quanti la fortuna di avere
un posto che possiamo definire casa e
spero in futuro di poterla aprire a
tutte quante quelle persone creative a
tutti quanti quei ragazzi che hanno idee
che hanno voglia di fare perché spesso
avere qualcuno che crede in te è la
chiave per poi riuscire a farcela e
vorrei che questo posto fosse un po un
posto di tutti più lo guardo più vi
voglio bene non so come dire è proprio
una roba bellissima bellissima e più di
quanto potessi mai chiedere ed è per
questo che ci stiamo mettendo tutto
l'impegno del mondo per riuscire a
trasformarlo in un posto ancora più
speciale di quello che già è noi ci
vediamo questa domenica con un nuovo
video su questo canale di cucina e poi
vi terrò aggiornati su quelle che spero
sia una evoluzione veloce ed enorme di
questo spazio ancora grazie
un bacio e ci vediamo presto ciao